hello and welcome
to the active inference live stream my
name is daniel friedman and this is
going to be a
solo discussion if you're a new listener
or not
welcome to team com we are an experiment
in online team communication and
learning
related to active inference you can find
us on twitter
at inferenceactive at activeinference
gmail.com
on key base via our public team or our
youtube channel
this is a recorded and archived live
stream
so please provide us with feedback so
that we can improve our work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here
and also as far as video etiquette goes
remember to mute if there's noise in the
background
raise your hand if you have a question
and so on
here we are in act imp stream number 5.0
we're kind of exploring with the
numbering system so give us any
feedback as far as what kinds of numbers
or what kinds of shows might be helpful
for
your learning but the goal for this
discussion is to set the context for
active in
stream 5.1 in 5.1
we're going to discuss the paper
multi-scale integration
beyond internalism and externalism by
ramstead at all 2019.
the goal of this video is really to
contextualize some of the ideas
the historical threads and the
vocabulary that will help you either
read or work with the ramstead paper uh
in terms of other
fields that you might be more familiar
with or just to sort of connect ideas
and thus ground your understanding and
your practice
so i come from a different background
from the author so i have a slightly
different perspective on
perhaps even the implications of the
paper so the goal here is really just to
explore that
so that whether you listen to this by
itself
and you're looking to sort of see where
active inference is trying to relate
itself to other philosophical ideas
or whether you're coming from the active
inference side and you want to
understand some of the broader
philosophical questions
that are being addressed potentially by
active inference in both those cases i
hope this is an interesting
video for you so here are a few of the
topics that we'll be
exploring here the first one is top-down
and bottom-up causation and that's going
to be an introduction to multi-level
systems as well as thinking about
causal modeling also
next we'll talk about and raise some
questions
related to partitioning between internal
and external cognition
which is certainly the wedge or the main
issue
that the ramps that at all paper is
going to be focused on
and then we'll talk about a few
different perspectives on systems
modeling
and action that's sort of action and
inference
if you will but there's also been a lot
of philosophical thought
on systems modeling as well as action so
we can kind of see how those two fields
might come together
in the field called active inference and
next time in number 5.1
we will all come together everybody who
wants to can always get in touch with us
we will all come together
and discuss the paper to whatever extent
we've read it
whatever we thought about it any
questions that we wanted to address
any of our background knowledge uh any
of our perspectives that we bring to the
paper those are all cool things
to come about in 5.1 and if you're
listening to this after 5.1 has happened
you can either listen to 5.1 or you
could get in touch with us to be on a
future
discussion so next time in
5.1 we're going to be talking about the
figures to abstract etc
in this paper by ramstead at all called
multi-scale
integration beyond internalism and
externalism and that's in the journal
synthes in 2019
so the goal of that paper and the only
quotes from the paper
that are going to be in this video are
just from the introduction
and abstract just so that we can ground
the
ideas more specifically in what ramps
that at all
frame their work asp so the goal of the
paper in the author's
words was we focus on making
explicit a description of the boundaries
of cognitive systems
that we think follows from taking
seriously the inactive
embodied and extended nature of
cognition
this is the idea that the boundaries of
cognitive systems
are nested and multiple and that with
respect to its study
cognition has no fixed or essential
boundaries
cool i think that that is really
exciting and also
it doesn't necessarily bring the free
energy principle or active inference
on too heavily it just helps understand
what is the broader
goal of the paper well the question
that really excited me today was this
taking it seriously aspect on
multi-scale integration
it's the first two words of the paper's
title
so maybe they're trying to signal with
that the story that we want to be
working towards is multi-scale
integration so
linking things that are different
spatial and temporal scales
at once multi-scale how are we going to
do
that multi-scale integration well what
they're
provocatively stating in the title is
that we must move beyond
this debate of internalism versus
externalism which i'll contextualize
soon
and the way that they're going to take
it seriously is using a mathematical
framework
called free energy principle and it's
related process theory
active inference so that's what taking
it seriously looks like for them
especially drawing on their background
as cognitive science
experts they're really framing this as
about multi-scale cognition
and i came from a not a cognitive
sciences background
more of an evolutionary biology
background and so
multi-scale integration in the ant
colony or in the insect brain or in the
cell
there's a different set of philosophical
baggage that comes along with it
sometimes if i could characterize it so
clearly would be the focus on humans
tends to focus on the experience
and the internal view since we are human
so at the very least it's one of the
ways that we can study
emergencies by ourself as an emergent
process whereas in
computers ant colonies the cell there's
often
a tendency following let's just say
dennit
and others to imagine it as an automata
or just sort of a robot
and therefore devoid of experience or
specularity
sorry speculatively having experience
but sort of on the sci-fi fringe and
anyways when you deal with the system
you have to be in that intentional
stance
so those types of systems tend to have
perspectives that are devoid of agency
whereas human systems the debate is just
about that
is about our own agency but we're all
part of the same multi-skill integrated
framework and so we want to have a story
that works for cells that are in our gut
that are in the uh in our gut lumen in
the microbiome why should it matter why
should we have a different theory of
biology for one side of that over the
other especially when we know that
there's
important transfer between them for
example so
the authors took it seriously and they
wrote this 2019 paper as well as other
papers
i'm gonna try to take this seriously
from
the work in biology that i have learned
about
over the years and that's what taking it
seriously and contextualizing looks like
to me so i just thought i could start
with that
here's a paper from 2012 by dennis noble
who's a great systems biologist
called a theory of biological relativity
no privileged level of causation so you
can kind of see
where he's going which is taking the
idea of relativity
whether that's gravitational relativity
something related to quantum mechanics
for example
or just uh inter-subjective relativity
like focusing on the relations that
define something or the interactions
that define a person
rather than an essentialist take so
noble is sort of taking
a broad understanding of relativity and
saying well if we really look at
multi-scale systems and spatial and
temporal cause
then there's going to be this relativity
principle maybe that could apply to
biology
and what i like about his figure one
and i've added two wrongs at the top is
that it really clearly phrases what he's
arguing against
and also makes it clear um how some of
these
logical errors become deployed in real
systems in real analyses
so figure one is a
model of causation for what's called
upward causation
and the way to read this figure is it
starts at the bottom
with the smallest thing which are genes
which here
is just i believe being meant as a
string of dna but that's a whole other
discussion
let's just say that genes uh are able to
cause proteins in rna which are another
scale of organization bigger moving up
towards protein and rna networks
up through cells tissues organs
organisms
social interactions ecological
technological
governance informational systems and so
on so this is a
sort of multi-scale systems perspective
and the
version of events that we often
get is implicitly one of what noble
is characterizing accurately as upward
causation
one could change the spatial metaphor it
could be moving downwards it could be
moving inwards or outwards
but suffice to say that this is what we
mean when we say upward causation is
really
from small things to big things because
the top down things are often seen as
big
and the things that are just on the
fabric level of reality are often seen
as small
rightly or wrongly um and
the the story when you have this type of
a
upward causation model again that
smaller things cause bigger things
is the the genes are upstream of the
behavior or
um the uh the cell damage is upstream of
the
organs so it makes sense and there's
also a related idea called supervenience
that is that
is there a relationship between changing
the smaller thing and the bigger thing
changing
so these are the kinds of questions that
come up and this is one
direction of causation however what
noble
ends up framing in this uh no
privileged level of causation model is
that yes there is
influence or flow from so-called the
upward direction so that's the genes
and uh going all the way up in
influencing things that are at larger
scale
but also in a very real and causal sense
there are top-down causation
that can be equally important for
regulating the system so even if in the
short time scale
the in uh influence of the bottom up is
extremely strong if there's no top-down
force sometimes
any amount of bottom-up power can just
cause the system to dissipate and
therefore not exist
so in that sense all systems that we
observe continuing to dissipate energy
for example like active inference
foragers informational foragers
humans living creatures we can
really start to see that there has to be
some sort of a top-down organizing force
otherwise it would be like a land uh
slide or a lightning strike it would
just dissipate away
so he says look because the top-down
forces are so important
and over evolutionary time end up
shaping the parameters and the set of
what is possible or functional at the
lower level
it really needs to have an equal hand
causally so
we also need to look at this from a
top-down bottom-up perspective
lots of people have thought about these
types of issues in systems theories
and in other areas but the three areas
that um i just want to emphasize here
before bridging to active inference
are that there's a continuum of larger
and smaller things
that has to basically be true because
you can't have something bigger inside
of something smaller
and in the context of this debate that
we're framing
uh to get set up for which is between
internalism and externalism
you can think about things that are
bigger as being more external and things
that are smaller as being more internal
so like the story about the smaller
things is going into the organ into the
cells
into our cells but the story going out
is about the ecosystem or the
the constructed niche and these are
things that are external
and so that's gonna come back later in
the paper
and then also um as a consequence of
that there's this nestedness
or this embeddedness to these different
levels of analysis
and there's again many vocabularies for
this type of recursive or embedded
system and hopefully we'll address some
but also
feel free to provide feedback these are
just some of the general aspects of
multi-scale systems
and some of the questions about
multi-scale systems that the paper is
going to address eventually
and the field of research but also
there's some philosophical work from
areas other than the inactive cognitive
area all right so the
next topic is going to be about
partitioning between internal and
external cognition which is another way
of
saying what is the internalism versus
externalism debate about how are we
going to move beyond that
how might the free energy principle be
involved in that
and in a sense the question that this is
asking
is how do we do causal modeling of
situations
where internal and external states
interact for example
through sense and action so let's think
about how sense and action are
interacting even at one level of
analysis what the ant
perceives for example in its actions
what you perceive and its actions
and then immediately one of the
questions that many people
have asked is okay so how do we make
that story
multi-level because the ant we could
simulate
it as just a robot with inputs and
outputs and sort of black box inside but
it
is also composed of the tissues and the
cells and it seems a little bit
ridiculous if we would have to simulate
from the cell
up to the ecosystem level so we have to
be able to
separate that model somewhere even if
only
for computational tractability or
comprehensibility so we got to make this
trade-off between
making causal models of systems that are
at one level of analysis
but including things that are at a
smaller level of analysis
that can have consequences that bubble
up for example a
drug binding to a receptor can bubble up
to behavior
that's like a story about upward
causation or someone's choice or
someone's context
could dictate their physiology through
any number of mechanisms which food or
molecules are available
so there is going to be times where that
cross-level interaction
is really important for the stories that
we tell for the narratives that how we
understand
the world um how we communicate about
those things so
how does the multi-level perspective
relate to causal modeling
if your story is about two people who
are fighting is the story only going to
be at that level or are you going to
bring in society are you going to bring
in the molecular
stuff how how much upper and lower
context do you provide for causal
modeling at a given
level of analysis
how is causal modeling related to the
possible actions of a system
also known as the adjacent possible
for example what else could be and this
just kind of reminds me of how when
someone describes
a near-miss or a situation that could
have been another way
they're not saying it could have been
any any other way
this thought experiment has been carried
out by gould
and others in the sense that yeah
something
happened a certain way which means it
was permitted by reality
and then you're envisioning a slightly
different scenario for example
the ball hits the other side of the roof
and it ends up rolling down a different
direction
doing some other outcome and the ball
still has the same physics and you're
still the same person so it's not any
alternate reality
it's a very tightly constrained causal
reality and what kinds of
alternate realities do people propose or
speculate
about ones that are within the causal
latent model of the world
where all stories where you cross the
freeway are dangerous for example
so that's the causal model that
underlies what we
genuinely generally are talking about
when we're talking about
what could happen we're not saying
anything could happen we're seeing a
pretty tight model
given about how we think about cause and
effect in the system
why is causal modeling so important to
active inference and there's two
roads into this i would say one
perspective
is why is causal modeling important from
the point of view the organism and
another
would be of the scientist or the
observer so
first from the point of the organism
there's a lot of ways to
frame exactly what it is an animal does
and a really
common area that people study this
without the
psycho baggage is in animal foraging
so whether it's a rodent or an ant
people or a bird people are really
interested
in the bioenergetics of and the
decision-making
that underlies how the animal uh goes
about searching for food
and how does that depend on the dynamics
of the ecosystem
and so one popular framework
in studying foraging is optimal foraging
theory
which you can just by the name of it
imagine is kind of like optimal
investing
strategy and there's a lot of variations
on it but it's just saying
what the ant is trying to do or what the
bird is trying to do
is given the costs and the benefits or
as estimated by the bird the predicted
costs and benefits
of the environment and the processing
time it's going to do this
reward maximization and
the good news about that approach is it
often works a lot of times animals are
near their predicted efficiency uh
however other times
it can be quite far off and it's not
exactly apparent why that might be
perhaps some constraint exists that was
not modeled
and so the reward maximization idea
often
succeeds or it captures a story or an
important variable about a foraging
system
as you might expect but it doesn't
really go the full way
in explaining how the model is embodied
or carried out by the animal
because it doesn't necessarily have the
kind of
computational processing that a human
simulation might
not to compare the brain or the niche to
a computer
but just to say that that even as a
physical computer imagined
is still something that's quite
different than the models that are being
used to study
the error divergence by which ultimately
people are going to be asking whether
the
strategy was optimal in terms of its
reward or not
what active inference does is it says
right the overall reward model is
intractable it
contains variables that are inaccessible
or just not realistic
for the nematode to be calculating for
example in any way
directly but what the animal can be
doing is
engaging in this cycle between action
and perception and so it
is making these sensory hypotheses about
the world
embodied through action so for example
the eyes are circading around very
rapidly
where are they moving they're moving to
where your brain predict predicts that
you need to resolve your uncertainty
about your visual field
most so that's why even though your
actual visual resolution
on your retina or the density of the
cells the ability to perceive
the fine granularity of vision is quite
different across the back of your eye
yet the whole visual field unless you
have some sort of visual alteration
is uniformly clear and doesn't have a
blind spot so that's
evidence that at least visually we're in
a generative model
of what's happening and it shouldn't be
too far
away to say that that's what other
animals are also having at least
visually with a total secondary question
of whether it's experiential or not but
just visually
so active inference is a process theory
that
we can go into more another time that
has to do with
how organisms actually act in their
ecological niche
to resolve their uncertainty about the
kinds of problems they actually need to
resolve
therefore framing things like foraging
as a reward
obtaining but a precision maximization
behavior sequence and that framing turns
out to have
big implications so just wanted to frame
it that way
as far as the scientist's active
inference
the scientist also from an informational
perspective
has to think about which hypotheses
they're
experimenting or modeling with to reduce
their uncertainty
about what and just
as in active inference where the
generative model of the internal
state the organism in this example the
scientist
the internal model includes a generative
model of the latent causes in the world
and understanding the latent causes
better is what facilitates
uh better action and also better
experiments and
hopefully clearer transmission as well
how does the markov blanket idea come
into play
what pierces the blanket so here any
figure that you look at
of the markov blanket is going to have
uh basically the active inference
cycle with a markov blanket superimposed
down the middle
there's internal and external states and
then external states influence
sensory states sensory states influence
internal states
internal states have their own
autonomous or self-influencing dynamics
and through policy selection end up
implementing action states for example
the movement of an arm
action states influence the external
states the world states for example
which are also of course involved in
their own dynamics
the markov blanket is pierced on one
side by sense coming
in and by action on the other side going
out
and then the whole multi-scale question
is going to be about applying that
markov blanket all the way down idea
taking that seriously as far as
cognition one other area
that i thought could be kind of
interesting to relate this to would be
like other partitioning problems and
another partitioning problem that comes
up in
biological philosophy realms is this
question of nature versus nurture
and here i would point people towards
two
pretty recent and excellent books on the
left is beyond versus the struggle to
understand the interaction of nature and
nurture
by james tabary and then on the right
the mirage of a space between
nature and nurture by evelyn fox keller
and
they both have a different perspective
on the same question but
in in both cases there's this idea of
moving beyond
the binary partitioning of nature and
nurture and
so here in the ramstead 2019 paper
the framing of internalism and
externalism where they're sort of
entering into this stack is at the level
of cognition it's about cognitive
entities
whereas here's a partitioning problem in
the area of genetics
and in environmental and developmental
studies for example
and here's an example of where similar
internalism
internals the genes right smaller things
or externalism
outside bigger things the ecosystem is
seen as bigger than the person
with this implicit focused level of
analysis on the individual
and so um just to draw on evelyn fox
keller's book
she uses a metaphor of different kinds
of tasks and how
even if you just had two people so the
same type of agent
if you had two people building a brick
wall together you could at the end of
the day
say well this person added so and so
many bricks and this person added the
rest of the bricks
and so maybe you could say well 40 of
the work on this wall was performed by
that person
however imagine a situation where two
people are needed to hold
a hose to fill up a bucket for example
even if one of the rules requires a
specialty
or more training or some other attribute
even in that case that person can't do
it alone
so no matter how much water comes
through that hose and it's all water
coming through the hose
you're never going to be able to say
well 80 of the water was due to person a
and 20 percent was due to person b
so she uses that really clear metaphor
to describe the relationship between
nature and nurture
how they're obviously related there is
no such thing as a
uh niche free organism especially when
you think about this from an
evolutionary
ecology or ultimately active inference
perspective
organisms and their niche are what
fitness is about
that is what is being fit to what is the
organism to their niche
and you don't see things that aren't fit
so it's unsurprising that we're
finally attuned to things in our niche
also there was a one interesting section
in mirage of a space between where she
traces the linguistic origins of the
framing
nature versus nurture because everyone
has heard the phrase nature versus
nurture is it nature or is it nurture
or it's in our dna it's in our nature
how did things come to be in this verses
sense that's also alluded to in the
title
of tabari's book and what fox
keller writes is recently a fashion has
arisen for tracing
the phrase nature and nurture and the
debate with which that phrase is
associated
back to shakespeare or at least to
prospero in the tempest
1623 who writes off caliban as
uneducable
quoting shakespeare a born devil on
whose nature
slash nurture will never stick
back to fox killer some have traced it
further
back to a monograph on children's
education written by an elizabethan
pedagogue
richard mulcaster mulcaster's words were
nature makes boy towered nurture sees
him forward
maybe it rhymes in another pronunciation
it's from 1581 and then
she concludes but in fact although both
molecaster
and shakespeare juxtapose the workings
of nature and nurture
neither invokes the term as an explicit
conjunction so not an or
they do not write of nature and nurture
as such
so they don't separate them and they
don't um make them
contra distincted versus each other
indeed when we look more closely at what
they do right we can see that their use
of the two terms does not invite
such a conjunction for there is no
presumption of an a priori disjunction
so what she's getting at there is
there really is no need to do an
argument against the concept of nature
and nurture
it's kind of like writing a hit article
on somebody who you disagree with
people who understand that there has to
be a move beyond
verses beyond an oppositional framing
of nature and nurture those people
should be and are making their positive
arguments
for why it should be framed a different
way
where the nature and the nurture are
things that are pulled out
or controlled for specifically and
transparently
in specific systems so that's an example
about how the philosophy of science
for example how we think about the
partition between internal and external
states
of phenotype relates to how we think
about multi-scale systems overall
because i think okay it reminds me so
much of this internalism and externalism
in cognitive sciences debate
reminds me a lot of this historical
debate in
genetics all right
next section perspectives on systems
modeling
and action and here the motivating
question
is about how do we carve nature at the
joints which is
a quote attributed to plato in the
phaedrus
allegedly and the quote alludes to
this idea that nature whether
one thinks that systems can be defined
tightly and they're just on their own
billiard
ball trajectory or whether one has a
relational perspective where there's
just these
multi-level networks of relations and
being and becoming
whatever it is at some point we want to
carve it at the joints
because otherwise we're going to get
swept up in the storm
and people will often hold that that's
not their position
or that they don't want to carve systems
at the joints but i think
if you're listening to this i hope you
can see that
at some point at least in action you
have to be
dealing with nature at the joints so to
speak are they the right ones or not
isn't that the whole question so
one thing that is a connection is
we can ask how is the fep the free
energy principle
or active inference going to help us
frame this problem of carving
nature at the joints this is kind of one
of the big
ideas from a philosophical perspective
is about classification and about
distinguishing
things whether it's objects or types of
processes
or um ideas distinguishing
things and those are part of nature is
part of philosophy and so coming back to
this
essential question of carving nature of
the joint and then
asking well how can we use things like
fep
active inference to frame the problem
structurally
to give us in ontology and in fact in
the paper they'll talk about an ontology
and
subsequent work also um worked on
ontologies
so that's sort of the big motivation
it's why
this quote is being brought up in the
context of this paper we're about to
discuss
because the whole point is about us
carving nature at the joints
so let's go a little bit deeper into
systems modeling and carving nature at
the joints
and the question is how are descriptive
we'll just call that type 1
and action oriented type 2 models
related or different
and so just to explain what those 1 and
2 are
by descriptive model i mean a system
description only and so two
examples just to sort of pin down the
qualitative to quantitative
spectrum the first mention here is to
bruno latour's
actor network theory or ant and
it's an awesome piece of maybe
meta sociology not sure exactly what the
torah would call it
that just says the way to approach the
system is by
showing up finding out what are the
traces and
being open with respect to which actors
are involved in which processes through
which
networks of influence so it's a very
unbiased
description or moving towards unbiased
not to step into that sort of uh
trap i guess and then um
it's very qualitative it's relational
it's also about
the observers knowing and relationship
with the system
not just the way that aspects of the
system are associated with each other so
often those things are left out in
quantitative or in some scientific
world use and on the other end of the
system's description
only spectrum i've pointed to
a package of complex systems
design tools called cadcad now cad cad
goes beyond
systems description it turns out to also
be able to do things like
simulation and and other
more dynamical approaches like signal
processing
but what i mean by putting cad cad here
is that it can be used
purely depictively to specify a complex
system
especially one that's computational so
there might be
a question when you're actually trying
to model a organic ecosystem
of how do you measure some every single
uh you know piece of the ecosystem and
how many variables is enough to describe
the fineness of the temperature gradient
or something like that
but when the simulation is about a
digital system
it can be more deterministically and
controllably
simulated if one can imagine so there's
one type of world modeling related to
system description
but that obviously enables simulation
and inference as well
the second kind of models are
action-oriented models
so action-oriented models are those
where
ultimately we're just we're assigning
meaning to states
voting with your fee voting with your
dollars it's
when we want to have effective action or
at least
the system acts like it wants to
something like maybe what dennett would
call the intentional stance
so the descriptive modeling might be a
question that you're asking the computer
like given this scatter of points which
axes capture the most statistical
variants
and that would be just it running some
sort of algorithm to find the maximum
variance explained
whereas a another type of algorithm like
more of a type 2
action-oriented algorithm might be learn
the relationship between
this input and the optimal performing
behavior
in the output so that's what
action-oriented models are about
next question how does the multi-level
perspective influence our answers above
so if we're going to have a story where
there's nature's being carved at its
joints maybe around the markov blankets
maybe with scents coming in and action
coming out
even if we have that at one level so we
have an asian-based model of the ants
that are bumping into each other and at
one level
the sense of one is the action of
another and so we have a sort of
bumper car model um where does the
multi-level perspective
come into play and that's kind of
thinking about the bumper car one it's
where you would model
first the cars bumping into each other
and then you could go into the engine
or you could go out to the power grid
and to the people who are
riding on the bumper cars or something
like that so
how are we going to deal with the
complexity of causal stories
relationships
some of what might which uh be really
important
and like the example of a molecule that
binds to a receptor
others which might be spurious and the
reality is that because of the
combinatorics
most of the options across levels will
be spurious
so most of the ecological relationships
can't be for example
one-to-one because there's so many that
are just bumping into each other all the
time
just to give one example from ecology so
how are we going to carve nature at its
joints
do it cleanly are we trying to represent
stuff like one are we trying to act like
two
do one and two fall out as a function of
doing one do we get
one and two as a function of following
out just two
how does emergence and emergent
properties fit into all of this
so by emergence or emergent properties
people often mean
a sort of system outcome where there's
some property or characteristic
or attribute that is arising at a higher
level
again bigger broader spatial and
temporal scales
based upon interactions or some sort of
interfacing
of the smaller level so sometimes these
emergent properties
using the classification here of badao
are
in the weak category and in the strong
category it's not the only way to break
down
immersions not to only take here but i
find this one pretty helpful
first strong emergence badao equates
with basically magic
you can read the papers more if you want
to
explore more nuance but the strong
emergence is from
something that's totally disjoint to
something that's
has a total integrity like language or
awareness for example and then weak
emergence is contrasted and that's most
of the
physical systems where even if the
relationships between subunits are
really nuanced
or the computational uh capacity
required to simulate the system would be
extreme
those systems are still weakly emerging
in that it still just is ants bumping
into each other
now they're developing and that's sort
of crazy and evolution shapes that and
everything
but still we're talking about a physical
system not in the
genre for example of um awareness
arising spontaneously so how is that
going to play into
uh the discussion with active inference
showing up on the scene
where will this relate to immersions
these are things
anyone's welcome to chime in on
also we can tie the idea of emergence
and the multi-scale systems approach
to this debate that we often hear about
reductionism versus holism so
reductionism
is simply a method of explanation
where bigger things are made sense of by
appeals to the properties of their
smaller things
like the bigger wall is um orange
because each of the smaller
pixels is orange or something like that
there's a variety of reductionist
explanations
and it's just one of our hands it's one
of our approaches or our wings
holism is kind of flipping that
uh schema of reductionism saying
actually smaller things
are made sensitive in terms of the
bigger thing
and that um is kind of the opposite
edge viewpoint and so we have some
sliding to
toward a holistic understanding some
sliding towards a reductionist
understanding a lot of
philosophical work in this area and the
thing that we would just want to note
here would just be
first ask continually how is the free
energy principle or active inference
relating to
reductionism versus holism because
sometimes
it may feel like there is a sort of a
philosophy of
science shift associated with taking on
the active inference framework
and so what are the implications of
taking that seriously where does that
put this reductionism versus holism
is it going to be put into a similar bin
as nature versus nurture
as kind of a turn of phrase or a false
dichotomy
that was just eventually seen through or
will there be people who still think
that that sort of binary phrasing
whichever side they find themselves on
is going to be appropriate and again
this is where dennis noble's
work on the bottom up and top down is
related
the other work here is girdle escherbach
which is the 1979 book
by douglas hofstetter and here's one of
the figures from the book where it says
uh mu mu i don't know how you'd say it
which is a allegorically at least
a sort of innovative response or a
canonical response
depending on who you ask of zen koan
and zen is a topic that's brought up in
the book
and the m is written
of letters that are containing smaller
letters that say reductionism
and then the u is made up of letters
that
spell out the other words so it's kind
of this multi-scale um
thought loop really captures the spirit
of the book well
and also it captures at least informally
through art as often is the case what it
looks like
to go beyond the reductionism versus
holism debate so first if only in a text
illustration but then eventually
how does that relate to a computer
screen how about a person interacting
with a computer screen
how about two people interacting with
their computer screens
all right few more perspectives on
systems modeling and action
how is world modeling related to
pragmatics and action
so the questions to ask here is really
is there a best map
of the territory uh short answer no
and this is true for geospatial maps as
well as
fields of affordances which we talked
about in the previous active streams
which also often demand to be mapped
for example skill set mappings or
concept mappings
so there's a lot to say about map and
territory of course
but for here it's suffices to say that
the best map
is defined by the mission by the context
by the degree of certainty by all these
other features and factors related to
the user
and the situation so we're talking about
making maps
uh of meaning maps for the world we're
talking about doing world modeling for
effective inference and action as we
were talking about previously
so here's just one quote from the paper
to
motivate you towards the things that you
might be able to hear them
expand more on they write the
multi-scale free energy principle model
allows us to cast the boundaries of
cognition as assembled and maintained in
an informational dynamics
across multiple spatial and temporal
scales
crucially we shall show that this
multi-scale application
of the fep free energy principle implies
both ontological
and methodological pluralism so a few
thought questions whether this is before
or after reading the paper
you could ask is the free energy
principle
pluralistic with respect to non free
energy principle theories
or frameworks or principles which
levels or types of theory is the fep
consistent or discordant with and one
starting point there would be
searching for carl fristen's interview
in the 2018
alias bulletin and it's an interesting
question to ask about any theory is okay
well who is this
changing the mind of or what is the
opposite of this theory and
is it true or does anyone hold the true
opposite
of this theory does anyone hold a 50
opposite is it 50 by outcome
or is it fifty percent by axiom in that
they diverge
so you can always ask that and i found
that that was a
very um interesting route to go down as
far as the fep
another quote from the paper is just
because it's such a
direct claim our claim is that
which among these which are the situated
barriers of
talking of systems which among these are
the most relevant will depend on the
phenomena being studied and the
explanatory interests of researchers
and so there's a few notions like
markov blanket which we talked about
earlier is that sense in action
piercing that's related to ecological
psychological concepts as well
the markov blankets
are defined in a few different ways
they're defined
by statistical covariations but
one type of those is going to be causal
and also another type of those could be
like a measurement
and so the kinds of measurements that we
make the types of causal relationships
that are important and then which models
we apply to them
is going to depend on uh what is enacted
by the researchers because they're also
part of embodied and cultured cognition
so briefly what are mythological and
ontological pluralism so
methodological pluralism means using a
variety of methods or ways of doing
ontological pluralism means having a
variety
of ontologies or ways of knowing
and pluralism is referring to there
being multiple
now there are other schools of thought
that are sort of higher order than
pluralism as to
how do you cut through that is it just
theory anarchy like um
fair bend suggested where the pluralism
can just be taken to this extreme
uh equivalent to almost a novelty search
in theory space
or is there going to be some way to cut
through that and determine
which of the pluralistic options or
possibilities or actualities
is preferable because ultimately we do
have to act that's that type 2 type of
model
so ask yourself for direct action
or for more philosophical topics what is
utilitarianism or pragmatism
how do such ideas relate to pluralism so
it's one thing to say we're scientists
and whichever level of analysis
is most relevant well that's going to
depend on what we're studying
and what we're interested in explaining
but
should it is that really the best way to
approach these systems
should we really um knowing that we can
never
remove for example individual bias
but still wanting to model systems so
that we can act effectively
how are we going to balance just this
sort of ruthless utilitarianism
pragmatism whatever ends justify the
means
um whatever preconceived worldview
whatever your bayesian prior is just
stick with that no matter what happens
how how is that related to cutting
through
the noise of pluralism
these are again just questions to raise
in active inference
how are ideas related to action and what
kind of ideas or mental states are there
there's a few kind of interesting
categories that we perceive at least
experientially various schools of
thought
on that but where are we going to fit
these into the active inference
framework are those just different loops
in our generative model things like
emotion
or desires or dreams or secrets
where are those going to fit into this
active inference
framework how integrated is that going
to be across
types of ideas
and how are our conserved or novel ideas
respectively meaning orthodoxy or
heterodoxy
associated with the expression of
conserved or novel actions
so that is ortho practice or
heteropraxis
and linking that to active inference
which is kind of
just framing this two-stroke engine or
this continual ooda
loop a lot of ways to think about it
it's just framing this continual flow
between
action and inference so how are those
two linked here's another way of asking
it
and just to conclude with two
books to study how this has been studied
from a philosophy of science perspective
on the right is scientific pluralism uh
edited by keller longino
and waters and then on the left is a
book called studying human behavior
how scientists investigate aggression
and sexuality by helen longneau
and these books talk about the
question of pluralism in science and
different ways that people have
sort of cut through the massive theories
or not
or contributed to it i guess in some
cases and there's just a really
interesting
body of thought and so it's uh useful to
think
for people who are in the free energy
space
as well as from the outside what are the
bridges that link
what's happening with the free energy
principle and active inference
to more classical philosophy of science
questions
and so hopefully in the first in
alias paper from 2018 and
also some other excellent work from the
last few years
we'll come to a better understanding of
that so
thanks for participating which i guess
was me and you as the listener
we will provide a follow-up form to live
participants
and we would welcome any feedback
suggestions
questions you have and yeah
stay in communication with us so
thanks again for listening and
we hope to either see you at 5.1 or
a future discussion